alright let's take another question here
this is again from the entrepreneur
subreddit which I love so much what are
your most effective networking tips to
help build valuable relationships I love
this question I'll take you back to Jay
Cal and 90s here's what I used to do I
was broke but I wanted to be powerful
and I wanted to network so what I would
do is I would go to a conference I
didn't have a ticket I'd hang out in the
lobby take out my laptop and I'd work
and I'd meet people I find one high
profile target and I'd say hey what are
you doing for dinner and they'd say
nothing to get plans I'm like no I got a
I got a I got a reservation for like you
know for six people you want to grab
dinner and yeah I'm like you want to
bring anybody say yeah great now I got
three people at dinner then I would take
their name so I'm like listen I got Fred
Wilson and Brad Feld coming to dinner
these are two venture capitalists then I
would ask for entrepreneurs I say yeah
I'm having a dinner with a couple of my
friends you want to come they bake oh
and I but yeah you know you know Fred
Wilson or Brad Feld
so I trade their names to get the next
CEO say but again oh I've always wanted
to meet him boom and I remember I did
this one time I was in I was oh maybe I
shouldn't tell a story should I tell the
story or not let me think
statute of limitations come by anyway I
was in I was in was that Sundance
because my friend David Sachs had a
movie thank you for smoking my friend
Elon Musk was also at Sundance cuz he's
in the movie and he I think he may have
backed it so we're all at Sundance
hanging out and what Mossberg was in
Sundance
so I even want Mossberg it he's like hey
let's get coffee or whatever and I was
like yeah yeah come over and I got my
friend Elon Musk him he's like I didn't
ask to meet this your friend I was just
gonna have coffee with you and he kind
of had money just a little bit about
doing this technique it just happened to
be he did it with Elon Musk who had just
invested in Tesla and I was trying to do
a favor for Elon to make sure Elon Musk
met Walt Mossberg I have the emails this
literally happened Walt Mossberg kind of
lectured me on you know using my meeting
with him to get a meeting for Elon which
is hilarious in hindsight but this was
my technique that was how I built those
valuable relationships I would just host
dinner and I would pay the bill now
I was broke so here's how I do it I
would go to a Mexican joint Mexican food
not expensive also if I would take this
two or three person dinner I'd make it
eight people then on the way in I'd say
don't bring menus to the table bring the
guac and chips bring the quesadilla and
I would just put out tons of and bring
three orders of fry heaters and put two
pictures of margaritas in the table
people would come the food would be out
already they started oh my god this is
great
okay city I love that now I've
controlled I didn't have everybody
ordering means I didn't everybody
ordering appetizers didn't have anybody
ordering their own drinks I got the
sangria it's cheap put a picture of beer
up there okay and it also saves every
time so they get working I get a two
hundred dollar bill or 150 dollar bill
from a Mexican joint for dinner of eight
with all these powerful people I pick up
the check I'm the mensch I was the
person bringing people together the
person who brings people together gets a
disproportionate amount of credit if you
introduce people to each other you
become the connector so that was my
simple technique going to events hanging
out in the lobby trying to leverage a
dinner with one or two people who I knew
and then just trade up socially trade up
right who needs to meet this person who
do they need to meet boom see if I can
bring people together
the other thing idea was I started my
own little magazine which was a zine
Silicon Alley reporter and I made a top
100 list well when you make the list of
the top 100 people
boy you're gonna be powerful you want to
see me doing it today in 2019 this
podcast you're soaking in it I've got
one of the number one business podcasts
investing podcast in the world when I
invite somebody on here when my friend
Tina Sharkey comes and talks about
Brenly she's gonna get customers and
so's the guy from helm who came on well
if I am ever gonna want to buy shares
and those two companies I've networked
with them I spent an hour with them
talking about their business I'm
interested in them so having a podcast
is this great excuse to spend an hour
with somebody and you're showing
interest in them so if you ever read how
to make friends win friends and
influence people whatever the Carnegie
Mellon one was or whoever wrote that
book who wrote that book how to win
friends and influence people I read it
like long ago but I think the basic Dale
Carnegie wrote it yeah this book this
how to win friends
and influence people is pretty
fundamental you know people will like
you if you're interested in them so the
six ways to make people like you become
genuinely interested in other people you
can make more friends in two months by
being interested in them that in two
years by making them interested in you
smile pretty basic remember that a
person's name remember that a person's
name is to that person's the sweetest
and most important sound in any language
be a good listener in our in encourage
others to talk about themselves talk in
terms of the other person's interest
make the other person feel important and
do so sincerely now if you deploy these
six ways to make people like you from
that book how to win friends and
influence people the reason that book is
always on the top ten business books of
all time is because it's true if you
show an interest in people you're gonna
make a connection with them the other
thing that makes a connection with
people is to be in a high stress or
memorable experience with him I took my
team scuba diving on the Great Barrier
Reef the people who went on that trip
are bonded forever we talk about it all
the time so another example of that is
taking people on a hike it doesn't have
to be a dangerous one but it if it is
dangerous they're probably gonna bond
more I'm not suggesting you do dangerous
stuff together but things that are peak
experiences for people they're going to
bond and if you're interested in people
it's gonna go a long way that's why
podcasting is such a fascinating medium
I believe it's because people are
showing genuine interest and the other
person and going really deep and so if
you look at sam harris if you look at
Bret Easton Ellis if you look at Joe
Rogan if you look at these people who
are becoming really good interviewers
and I hopefully I'm in that category as
well when you become a good interview
and you have short questions and you
listened deeply and you create a
follow-up question based on the answer
that's my big technique so when you
watch the podcast I'll ask somebody a
question and then sometimes you'll say
to yourself oh Jason that's the same
question I was thinking that's because
I'm thinking of you my viewer my
listener and I'm thinking what question
will you have when listening to that
person's answer so when I'm listening to
an answer I'm not thinking about my next
question I'm thinking about what
question to you the audience have
based on the answer so I was watching
this interview with George Lucas once at
a benefit dinner and they had asked me
to interview him and I was like oh my
god that's incredible and then they gave
somebody else the interview and I was
kind of crushed about it but the purge
or look I said during the interview you
know and they were like oh and what
influenced you from thx to you know Star
Wars were blah and he said well you know
when I got in the car accident that
changed everything and I kind of looked
at the world a little differently and
then the person like looks at their cue
cards in like so the Empire Strikes Back
and I'm like whoa George Lucas was in a
car accident and it changed the way he
looked at the world you didn't ask the
question everybody in the room was
thinking what what how did his thinking
change where did this accident a car was
anybody else in the car what kind of car
was driving which it wasn't a two way
road was it on the highway was there
snow did it spin out I mean come on
so anyway podcasting is the little hack
even if your podcast only gets 500
people listening to it and it's about
something incredibly niche I would look
at a podcast as a way to do 10 episodes
to meet 10 people you want to and bond
with them it's a killer killer little
hack so anyway great question